j'ai j'ai soulevé le problème Athos le 2
août dernier le 2 août 2023 dans une
tribune qui a été scigné par 82 de mes
collègues au moment où effectivement le
groupe atthos risquait d'être vendu à
des mains étrangères pour une raison
assez simple c'est que Athos est un
acteur de la souveraineté française en
matière de dissuision nucléaire
notamment avec un avec un un système qui
s'appelle enfin que sont des super
calculateurs qui ont pour vocation à
simuler des Ess nuclire c'està-dire que
depuis 96 date d'arrêt des essais
nucléaires euh toutes les informations
qui ont été euh j'allais dire récupéré
suite aux ESS nucléaires ont été mises
dans un gros ordinateur si je résume les
choses et aujourd'hui ces gros
ordinateurs qui sont des super
calculateurs qui sont détenus par atthos
permettent de simuler des essas
nucléaires et donc ils sont évidemment
un des outils essentiels de la de
l'indépendance française euh et entre
autres il y en a d'autres aussi le cyber
aussi est est un outil euh par largement
développé par Atos et qu'il maîtrise
largement et donc ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas c'est que ces compétences
soient euh prises en compte par des
puissances étrangères et donc nous avons
dès le mois d'août dernier avec 82 de
mes collègues lancé un appel au
gouvernement et et et et à l'état pour
pour dire que il y avait urgence à être
à faire preuve de prudence sur ce
dossier les choses ont bougé puisque
tout a été quelque peu bloqué et puis et
puis aujourd'hui on essaie de de de
trouver les solutions mais atos est dans
une situation économique très difficile
et donc nous sommes très prudents dans
la manière dont nous abordons les choses
mais en tout cas avec la commission des
affaires économiques euh et la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées nous allons
faire une mission commune qui doit
commencer son travail très prochainement
au tout au tout début du mois de février
pour travailler sur cette question
d'Atos et comprendre ce qui s'est passé
et nous n'excluons pas avec Dominique
Estrosi Sasson la présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques si
toutefois euh les personnes que nous
souhaitons rencontrer n'étaient pas
suffisamment compréhensives nous
n'excluons pas de transformer cette
mission d'information en commission
d'enquête afin de pouvoir aller jusqu'au
bout des demandes que nous faisons et
que nous formulons à la société mais
aussi à l'état français et quelle
personne vous souhaitez auditionner il y
aura beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
qui ont à un moment ou à un autre été
j'allais dire dans le dans le jeu ou
dans le dans le dans dans le dans le
dans le destin d'Atos il a il y a une
multitude de de personnes qui voulent
que les directeurs passent les uns après
les autres se succède il y a Daniel
krtinski fera partie des personnes
auditionnées écoutez je je ne ferai pas
partie de la commission les rapporteurs
on vont être désigné par la commission
demain ils l'ont été par la commission
affaires éco je crois la semaine
dernière ce sera à eux de décider de qui
ils souhaitent auditionner mais en tout
cas ce que nous souhaitons c'est mettre
en œuvre un rapport qui permette de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé chez
Atos